los tres puntos trazados abajo están en
la gráfica que es igual a b elevado a la
equis estos tres puntos de aquí
basándose únicamente en estos tres
puntos traza los tres correspondientes
que deben estar en la gráfica de james
es igual a logaritmo en base fede x haz
clic en la gráfica para trazar estos
puntos y bueno primero déjame pegar esta
pantalla aquí en donde podamos
trabajarla en este pizarrón y ahora
fíjate en lo siguiente los tres puntos
trazados de abajo están en la gráfica y
es igual a b a la x qué información nos
dice eso bueno para esto déjame hacer
una pequeña tabla por aquí hablando de
esta primera función
la primera función es la función a
déjame tener esta tele aquí aquí tengo a
x mientras que por acá tengo a james
alguien que por cierto lo obtenemos con
b elevado a la equis de lujo
ahora que nos dicen estos tres puntos si
te das cuenta
el primer punto nos dice que cuando x
vale 0 y vale 1 cuando x vale 0 ok ya
toma el valor de 1 es justo la
información que me está dando este punto
de aquí ahora el segundo punto lo que me
dice es que cuando x vale 1 y vale 4
cuando x vale 1 y vale 4 y de hecho de
que ya podríamos obtener el valor de bem
si x vale o no vale 4 y bueno podríamos
hacer algún ajuste para saber el valor
de ben y es la información que me está
dando este punto de aquí ahora por
último tengo este otro punto de por acá
que me dice que cuando x vale 2 que toma
el valor de 16 cuando x vale 2 que toma
el valor de 16 y bueno estos tres puntos
son puntos que están en gráfica y es
igual a b a la equis ahora lo que
queremos hacer es graficar los tres
correspondientes puntos pero de eso
otra función así que qué te parece si
hacemos otra tabla por aquí déjame tomar
en este color y voy a hacer otra nueva
tabla por aquí tengo esta tabla de por
acá ok y en esta tabla me voy a tomar
esta función que esencialmente si te das
cuenta es la función inversa en este
caso aquí tendría a equis déjame poner
con este color aquí tendría x mientras
que aquí tendría la función que es igual
a logaritmo en base b ok de x es decir
la función inversa bueno y cuáles son
las posibilidades aquí ahora qué te
parece si tomamos justo estos valores
porque recuerda que la función logaritmo
es la función inversa de la exponencial
y la función exponencial es la función
inversa del logaritmo y por lo tanto si
yo me tomo ahora estos valores que tengo
aquí a la izquierda que voy a obtener
vamos a ponerlos aquí si yo tengo que
ahora x va a valer 1 ok
después va a tomar el valor de 4 lo voy
a poner justo
aquí y después va a tomar el valor de 16
después va a tomar el valor de 16 que
voy a obtener con esta función bueno si
te das cuenta en primer lugar tengo el
logaritmo el logaritmo en base b y en
este caso de x que es 1 y bueno si ves
una potencia distinta de 0 y bueno eso
lo podemos notar una manera muy sencilla
en cómo se comporta esta función aquí el
logaritmo en base b de uno siempre cero
para cualquier base distinta de cero b
elevado a la potencia cero nos da este
resultado siempre 1 por lo tanto en este
caso me queda el punto 10 el punto 10 y
tiene todo el sentido lógico del mundo
que lleguemos justo a este punto de aquí
si te das cuenta lo que hicimos fue
invertir la equis por la yema y la ye
por la equis aquí estamos en el punto 0
1 y aquí estamos ahora en el punto 10 y
bueno es que realmente cuando te tomas
la función inversa lo que estás haciendo
es
a través de la función a identidad a
través de la recta y es igual a x así
que si nos fijamos en esta recta lo que
estoy haciendo es reflejando lo a partir
de esta recta de aquí tenemos una
reflexión ahora si nos fijamos en el
siguiente que vamos a obtener tendría en
este caso el logaritmo el logaritmo en
base b de 4 es decir a qué potencia
tengo que llevarme para obtener 4 pero
eso nosotros ya lo sabemos es justo lo
que dice aquí hay que elevar a la
primera potencia para obtener el valor
de 4 cuando x vale 1 b elevado a la 1 es
4 a qué potencia tengo que elevar a b
para obtener 4 bueno pues eso lo sabemos
es la potencia número 1 y por lo tanto
tendría el punto 4 1 4 1 es este punto
de aquí y si te das cuenta tiene toda la
lógica del mundo es una reflexión sobre
la recta
x de lujo ahora fijémonos en el último
punto cuánto va a valer el logaritmo mba
se ve de 16 es decir a qué potencia
tengo que elevar a b para obtener 16 y
eso nosotros lo sabemos es a la segunda
potencia porque ve cuadrada de cuadrada
es lo mismo que 16 cuando equivale a 210
vale 16 a qué potencia tengo que elevar
para obtener 16 bueno pues esto es a la
segunda potencia y estaríamos en el
punto 16 2 justo este de aquí y qué
creés
también estamos fijándonos en una
reflexión alrededor de esta recta la
recta y es igual a equis o dicho de otra
manera lo que estamos haciendo es
intercambiando los valores de x por
james y por equis y bueno ya justo aquí
tengo los tres correspondientes puntos
que era lo que me pedían así que es un
buen momento para sacar la página
internet el navegador y vamos a poner
nuestra respuesta y 10 que al final nos
dando la idea de tener dos funciones que
son funciones inversas y es por eso que
entonces el punto cuando x vale cero y
llévale uno vamos a tomar nuestro punto
correspondiente cuando x vale 1 y vale 0
que sería este punto de aquí y después
el punto en donde x vale 1 y ya vale 4
entonces su correspondiente punto es
cuando x vale 4 y ya vale 1 es justo
este de aquí y bueno aquí tenemos el
punto en donde x vale 2 y lleva al de 16
y su correspondiente punto sería cuando
x vale 16 y ya vale 2 y justo tenemos
estos tres puntos de aquí y bueno si te
das cuenta esto se ve claramente porque
son funciones inversas así que es
momento de comprobar la respuesta y
perfecto estamos bien